[Musique]
le bonsoir très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle saison
d'informations locales sur tv 60,18 le
journal de la rédaction
20 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité yvelinoise avec reportages
invités et chronique voici les titres de
ce mercredi 2 septembre
c'est une saison estivale particulière
qui s'apprête à se terminer conditionné
bien sûr par l'épidémie de kovy 19 les
vacanciers ont changé leurs habitudes
avoir ne sont pas partis du tout quel
est le premier bilan du tourisme dans la
région et dans les yvelines
éléments de réponse le département qui
est classé en zone de circulation active
du coronavirus conséquence le préfet des
yvelines a pris des mesures
complémentaires à celles du gouvernement
le port du masque est désormais
obligatoire aux abords des gares et
écoles du territoire
et puis du football avec un derby
yvelinois ce soir en nationale 2 d'un
côté poissy et ses stars laurent
fournier sur le banc clément chantôme
sur le terrain de l'autre le premier
versailles c'est à 20h nous irons
prendre la température sur place à la
fin de ce journal
mais dans l'actualité de la semaine il
ya bien sûr cette rentrée des classes
plus de trois cent mille élèves des
yvelines ont fait ou vont faire leur
retour sur les bancs de l'école du
collège et du lycée une rentrée pas
comme les autres avec l épidémie de kobe
de 19 dans toutes les têtes pour les
plus de 11 ans d'ailleurs le port du
masque est obligatoire pendant les cours
c'est le cas au collège notamment
comment cette rentrée at-elle été vécue
marie pas neutre à et patrick jacques de
dixmude sont allés à poser la question
au collège des prés à montigny le
bretonneux où léa 6e sortait justement
de leur premier jour de cours garder ça
s'est très bien passé
donc on est rentré puis on va expliquer
des choses sur le collège
on a dû garder le masque et se
désinfecter les mains à chaque rentrée
en cours et ensuite pendant la
récréation devait garder un mètre de
distance et se laver les mains aussi en
c'est une bonne organisation et c'était
sympa
oui ça va être compliqué parce que bon
on peut pas vraiment voir le visage des
gens donc on peut pas voir c'est une
souris s'ils sont plutôt pas très cool
où on peut pas vraiment voir alors oui
je pense que ça va être un oubli dire
que d'habitude il était par action
puisque elle vient de rentrer en 6e donc
elle savait pas où elle allait mettre
les pieds on a essayé tant bien que mal
de la rue ils étaient plus stressé pour
sa rentrée en 6e que le fait de porter
le masque on a été rassuré par la
réunion d'information ce matin
et puis on va voir par la suite ce qu'il
en est en fête avec les mesures ce qui
avec le concret en fait tout simplement
ob attrape le conjoint d'une enseignants
de la maternelle maurice thorez a été
testé positif aux copies 19 résultat les
professeurs de l'établissement n'ont pas
pu assurer leur classe hier et ont dû se
soumettre à des dépistages dans la
matinée de mardi éducation nationale et
municipalités se sont mobilisés pour
pouvoir accueillir normalement les
enfants une équipe de cinq enseignants
et deux assistantes d'éducation a pu
prendre la relève
une entrée masqué mais aussi mieux
équipée nous avons relayé hier la
distribution de 160 mille masques opéré
par le département des yvelines la
collectivité elle va aussi faire don de
5000 tablettes aux collégiens l ile de
france de son côté qui a la compétence
des lycées va faire don de milliers
d'ordinateurs portables aux élèves de
seconde annonce hier depuis
mantes-la-jolie de la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse un don d'un
montant de 180 millions d'euros
l'objectif réduire la fracture numérique
il en a été beaucoup question pendant le
confinement et faciliter aussi les
éventuels périodes d'enseignement à
distance avec cette dotation environ 75%
des élèves franciliens de seconde et de
première vont disposer d'un ordinateur
personnel est dans l'actualité également
le port du masque qui est devenu
obligatoire aux abords des gares et
écoles yvelinoise et ce depuis le 1er
septembre une décision et préfectorales
anticipé déjà par plusieurs maires du
territoire qui avait pris à des arrêtés
similaires
et dès le mois d'août nickel et demi
d'euros la mesure était déjà actif sur
les marchés brocantes et vide-greniers
elle est désormais élargie porter un
masque est obligatoire dorénavant aux
abords des établissements scolaires et
universitaire ainsi qu'autour des gares
ferroviaires à l'arrêté du préfet des
yvelines prévost pendant un mois dans un
rayon de 50 mètres autour de ces sites
pour les personnes de plus de 11 ans en
cette matinée de rentrée dans cette
école primaire du vésinet la mesure est
plutôt bien accueillie et rassure les
parents c'est important pour protéger la
santé des autres et la santé de nos
enfants
moi je pense que vous faites une bonne
chose qu'il faut porter le masque dès
lors qu'on sort de son de son domicile
il faudrait que ce soit généralisé dans
toute la ville pour pâques et
d'ambiguïté pour savoir si oui on peut
le porter ici si oui on peut pas le
porter dans une dizaine de communes des
yvelines les mères avaient anticipé
l'arrêté préfectoral et pris des
décisions similaires dès le mois d'août
c'est le cas d'ailleurs au vésinet où le
port du masque est obligatoire dans
plusieurs lieux de forte affluence de la
ville depuis le 17 août
j'ai pris cette décision par principe de
précaution puisqu'il y avait une
évolution quand même assez significative
du virus dans les yvelines et donc on a
voulu le faire suffisamment tôt avant
que les gens reviennent de vacances de
façon à les habituer et d'avoir une
bienveillance sur la première semaine de
l'arrêter pour que après tout soit bien
respecté même stratégie du côté de la
municipalité de villepreux qui avait
pris ses dispositions dès le 17 août
également après une phase de tolérance
auprès de la population la fermeté sera
de mise l arrêté et respectés en tout
cas le port du masque est respecté il ya
eu un petit moment on va dire où il ne
l'était pas c'était le temps que
l'arrêté soit compris et soit connue de
tous notamment de la part des
commerçants mais globalement aujourd'hui
c'est bien respectée en continu sur le
terrain à faire de la pédagogie de la
communication et puis avec la police
municipale on rentrera aussi maintenant
dans une phase de faire de verbalisation
à si besoin est l'amande pour non
respect de l'arrêté peut grimper jusqu'à
135 euros
depuis le 27 août les yvelines ont été
placées en zones de circulation active
de lakovic 19 et depuis le 1er septembre
le masque est également devenu
obligatoire pour tous les salariés des
entreprises pas de gros changement pour
ces deux sociétés à qui nous avons rendu
visite
elles avaient déjà pris leur disposition
le reportage de célia agathe songo
astrid bergère justin brasier et nicolas
dandrès lorsque deux salariés sont dans
une même pièce
le port du masque est désormais
obligatoire dans cette entreprise de
formation à la cybersécurité à
guyancourt quelques restrictions ont été
mises en place afin de limiter le
brassage de personne n'a limité le
nombre de personnes personnes dont
chaque salle a une affichette dix ans le
nombre de personnes qui doivent rester
au maximum dans la salle de façon
statique dans cet autre entreprise
d'ingénierie informatique situé à
montigny le bretonneux
le directeur général est encore allé
plus loin depuis on va dire le démarrage
de la pandémie jusqu'à maintenant un
salarié doit avoir au moins un test
négatif pour qu'on puisse effectivement
s'assurer que tout va bien
certains salariés sont en lien direct
avec des clients les échanges se font
donc eux aussi masqué on a affaire
principalement à des clients qui bat qui
ont également mis en place ces mêmes ces
mêmes gestes et donc on respecte bien
entendu alors ça c'est impressionnant de
temps en temps c'est qu'on a des grandes
salles de réunions pour 400 personnes on
respecte bien entendu tout ce qui est
différent ciation geste on fait bien
attention de passe donné du matériel
informatique avec toutes ces mesures
sanitaires à respecter les relations
entre les salariés pourraient être moins
agréable mais c'est sans compter sur le
dynamisme de la responsable marketing
on peut dire que je suis la personne qui
créent l'animation dans le bureau donc
c'est pas le masque qui va m'empêcher de
rigoler ou de face et la petite vanne
pendant le confinement 45 % des
franciliens étaient en télétravail
trois mois après seuls 14 % le sont
encore
[Musique]
on parle à présent tourisme dans ce
journal quel est le premier bilan de la
saison estivale est aussi celle du
premier semestre dans les yvelines avec
ce paramètre qu'ovide 19 qui a forcément
changé la donne on va poser la question
à mes deux invités en plateau avec moi
joséphine coleman ce berger bonsoir
maire de la commune de plaisir vous êtes
également la vice présidente du conseil
départemental des yvelines en charge
notamment du tourisme fabrice le loueur
bon soir vous avez vous le directeur du
parc france miniature c'est à elancourt
merci d'être avec nous avant de vous
donner la parole ces chiffres sans
surprise l'activité touristique a été
touché de plein fouet par l'épidémie de
coronavirus et des nuitées d'hôtel / 6d
fréquentation de sites culturels bessan
parfois jusqu'à 70 % mais l'été a
redonné une petite bouffée d'oxygène on
fait le point avec mélanie poker perte
de recettes de parking les forte
diminution des activités commerciales à
versailles là que 29 et le confinement
ont laissé des traces
la taxe de séjour et un montant
significatif si on est sims ou les cours
comme hull et on pense qu'on a perdu à
peu près 8 millions d'euros de recettes
avec les dépenses nouvelles
c'est considérable pour notre budget sur
six mois le domaine de versailles a vu
son nombre de visiteurs baissaient de
77% par rapport à 2019
c'est 60% pour le château de rambouillet
au musée d'archéologie nationale de
saint germain en laye la baisse est de
40% depuis la réouverture fin juin grâce
à l'été culturel du ministère on est
pathétique à une situation publique et
aux enfants des ateliers
d'expérimentation dans la cour qui ont
très bien marché
nous avons accueilli six enfants sur les
deux mois
le camion issus des quartiers politique
de la ville autre secteur durement
touché celui de l'hôtellerie les nuitées
en juin ont été divisés par six par
rapport à 2010 neuf annulations de
séminaires réduction de voyages
d'affaires
le remplissage n'atteint parfois que 20%
ce qui s'est plutôt bien passé c'est les
mois de juillet août avec un taux de
remplissage qui était quasiment
équivalent à celui de les années
précédentes
mais avec une baisse de prix de 25% par
rapport aux années précédentes
14 millions de touristes en moins un
manque à gagner de 6 milliards d'euros
pour aider à la relance la région
ile-de-france créer un label de sécurité
sanitaire ce label répondra à des normes
drastiques de sécurité sanitaire il
pourra être affiché dans les bars dans
les cafés dans les hôtels dans les
musées pour prouver à tous nos clients
qu'ils soient français ou étrangers que
nous sommes une région sûre en
ile-de-france au tourisme ces cinq cent
mille emplois et 7 % de la richesse sur
2020 la région estime que seulement 20
millions de touristes la visiteront en
ils étaient 50 millions mais joséphine
coleman ce berger peut-être nous n'avait
pas de chiffre précis encore à nous
donner mais au sortir de l'été ce que la
tendance globale décrite dans ce
reportage à savoir une chute au premier
semestre mais une reprise même minime
cet été ce que vous l'avez observé aussi
dans le département des yvelines oui
tout à fait on l'a observé heureusement
on s'est rendu compte que bien sûr on
n'avait pas tous le tourisme et
étrangers que nous avons l'habitude de
recevoir mais en tout cas au niveau
francilien il y à une redynamisation va
dire de tous les espaces et nous avons
la chance d'avoir beaucoup d' espace
jeudi en ouverture avec des espaces
verts et des activités extérieures qui
permettent bien sûr une relance que l'on
ressent aujourd'hui on a observé avant
les vacances au moment notamment des
week-end de la pentecôte et de
l'ascension que les franciliens se
tourner davantage vers des destinations
plus local l'égide de la vallée de
chevreuse ont été pris d'assaut pendant
ses week-ends sassine tons mauves qui
qui a pu continuer pendant le tfc qui a
continué est on est on est très présent
aussi pour accompagner tout cela puisque
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec le
département à accompagner aussi par par
des moyens qui sont des moyens comme les
passes malin puisque tout ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été mis en place
pour permettre aux familles d'avoir des
réductions importantes et donc on a été
effectivement pris d'assaut dans
certaines dans certains lieux qui
pendant l'été et l'était beaucoup moins
puisque les gens partaient
plus loin en france ou à l'étranger
précise que le pass malin c'est une
carte qui permet à de jeunes chinois à
leurs familles de pouvoir accéder à des
tarifs préférentiels sur des sites
yvelinois aussi alto séquanaise qui est
un partenariat au sein au sein de cet
établissement public interdépartemental
fabrice la loure nous vous avions rendu
visite au moment de la réouverture du
parc france miniature c'était le 26 juin
dernier les trois mois de nos ouvertures
avant les vacances représentait cent
mille visiteurs attendus en moins est-ce
que c'est reparti depuis cet été
alors c'est reparti les cent mille
visiteurs par contre qu'ils sont
manquants sur le début de saison cela ne
peuvent pas être reportée 1,7 et les
scolaires c'était les ponts de mai
c'était des vacances de d'avril qui
évidemment sont très fortes pour nous
donc a pas de report de ce mr assurent
les mois d'été par contre les mois d'été
ont été plutôt bons on avait anticipé
une perte évidemment des visiteurs de
l'ordre de 25% et c'est ce qui s'est
avéré le cas à la fin août nous allons
perdre 25 % de visiteurs ce qui est
beaucoup mais ce qui est plutôt une
fourchette haute en terme de d'attendus
est ce que ces trois mois de nos
ouvertures ou était une menace pour moi
dire la pérennité et la pérennité du du
parc france miniature est ce qu'il a été
menacé de fermeture où vous avez eu les
reins assez solides alors france
miniature à un équilibre financier qui
est fragile et ça depuis sa conception
depuis 30 ans puisqu'on va fêter notre
trentième anniversaire donc fragile
monde dur et heureusement france
miniature fait partie d'un groupe qui
est solide qui est la compagnie des
alpes et qui nous a permis de tenir et
d'avoir une ossature forte pour pouvoir
passer ce cap qui est difficile mais
c'est vrai que des sites qui n'ont pas
le moyen d'être appuyée sur un gros
groupe connaissent statham en difficulté
autrement plus sévère que france
miniature et pour passer ce cap
justement est-ce que c'est passé par des
embauches en main cet été de deux
saisonniers ce que il ya aussi des
réductions d'effectifs qui ont été
opérés tout à fait alors il ya eu à la
fois dans un premier temps la nécessité
d'engager davantage de personnes pour
l'entretien pour la sécurité promettant
passe au protocole sanitaire
donc pour les contrôles de sécurité pour
le nettoyage et l'entretien
mais après il a fallu s'adapter aux
visiteurs est évidemment moins de
visiteurs c'est moins nombreux nous
reste aux lancers moment dans les
boutiques dont moins de ceux de ces
zones et c'est moins 25% de saisonniers
sur la période on
16 permanents et 50 un peu plus de 50
saisonniers sur l'été dernier et là on
en avait 25 % moment avec des
perspectives inconnu on sait pas
vraiment comment va évoluer cette
épidémie claude et phil mccoleman berges
on est on est on est comme tout le monde
a ainsi pu vérifier
malgré tout on a pu constater une une
sérénité malgré tout parce qu'on se rend
compte que les structures qu'elles
soient et collectivités locales les
intercommunalités le département
accompagne aussi énormément sur tous les
protocoles sanitaires
donc on se rend compte que la population
commence je dirais non seulement à
adopter et tous et tous tous ses gestes
mais en plus la confiance renaît donc on
a de nouveau un mouvement appelle avec
des familles et puis l'ouverture des
écoles aujourd'hui la reprise école va
permettre aussi peut-être de réengager
le dire et ne serait ce que dans votre
structure des possibilités aussi de
déplacement de des scolaires et ça peut
redonner aussi une dynamique dans
certains lieux qui sont des lieux
touristiques avec des accompagnements
sanitaires bien sûr mais des
accompagnements fille aussi financier
par les collectivités et les
départements est ce que vous êtes aussi
confié fabrice la loure précise que la
saison de france miniature ne niera pas
jusqu'à la fin de l'année on ça se
termine en octobre novembre
comme chaque année en fait le parc est
ouvert pendant sept mois il s'arrêtera
au 1er novembre à la fin des vacances de
toussaint pour reprendre qu'au mois
d'avril prochain et on anticipe là aussi
une saison un début de saison qui sera
compliqué puisque tant que la crise
n'est pas complètement terminée
évidemment il restera quelques traces un
petit mot pour terminer qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce qui a été annoncé dans
le reportage ce label de sécurité
sanitaire est ce que ça peut rassurer
davantage et touriste est ce que le
département des yvelines prévost 6,2 des
actions complémentaires sur sur le
tourisme oui on est on est dans des
démarches qui sont des démarches
je dirais presque au coup par coup parce
que ce qui se passe au niveau de cette
maladie et bien nous arrive un petit peu
de façon haché et on sait pas très bien
donc on essaye toujours d'accompagner la
juste permettez moi de dire que au
niveau de cet été on a mis en place les
quartiers d'été avec le département qui
ont permis à beaucoup d'enfants de se
déplacer et d'aller dans des lieux du
département pour pouvoir avoir des
vacances et bien évidemment moi je
trouve très
très positif ce qu'a mis en place madame
valérie pécresse au niveau de la région
tout ce qui est je dirais accompagnement
avec ce bon sens cela ne peut que nous
accompagner et nous aider les
départements sera bien sûr aux côtés de
tous nos opérateurs pour pouvoir les
accompagner du mieux possible pour qu'on
sorte de cette crise la tête haute
tous merci pour vos réponses merci pour
votre présence en plateau merci à vous
joséphine coleman verger et à fabrice la
loure toutes les informations sur le
parc france miniature et aussi sur le
secteur du tourisme dans le département
via les deux liens qui s'affiche en bas
de l'écran
[Musique]
le sport et du football on a le droit à
un derby yvelinois ce soir pour la
troisième journée de nationale 2 c'est
la quatrième division nationale de
football
l as poissy reçoit le fc versailles
promu cette saison coup d'envoi à 20
heures au stade léo lagrange à poissy
sur place on retrouve ni quel ennemi d'
eurobonds soir mickaël ce sont deux
équipes ce soir qu'ils auront à coeur de
lancer définitivement leur saison
oui grigori ce sera d'autant plus vrai
pour poissy qui a perdu ses deux
premiers matches de la saison
je suis avec le président olivier c'est
luc olivier est-ce qu'il faut gagner
impérativement ce soir bah écoutez vous
connaissez effectivement quand on
démarre une saison avec une première
défaite à domicile contre loi est
derrière sur rouen où l'on perd le
deuxième match sur les faits de jeu
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est
primordial je veux dire que à partir du
moment où on avait fixé un objectif
d'être entre la 5e 10e place et surtout
pas revivre les années précédentes où on
a joué tout le temps la descente nous
battons a effectivement nous mettant
dans une position compliquée dès le
début je crois que ce soir c'est c'est
primordial alors versailles est une très
belle équipe sont montés nationale 2 sur
une belle dynamique
nous on pensait compte tenu des joueurs
qu'on avait fait signer mais c'est c'est
vrai que j'ai envie de vous dire en tant
que président je suis déçu certes mais
sur le fond de jeu sur ce qu'on a fait
depuis le début de saison s'est défait
de jeu on perd 1 0
une fois 1-0 alors mais pas de but c'est
peut-être le souci néanmoins ce soir oui
c'est primordial c'est évident c'est un
derby
quels seront les recettes pour remporter
la victoire c'est avant tout la
détermination
oui mais c'est un match comme un autre
que ce soit vers ça et que ce soit
plabennec que ce soit guingamp c'est sûr
que
compte tenu du fait que c'est un derby
versailles monte on a eu entre l'année
dernière montée descendu j'espère
j'espère très sincèrement que l'on
pourra on pourra montrer que l'ess
poissy temps nationale depuis des années
quand même donc y monte en nationale 3
ils sont inexpérimentés à ce niveau là
néanmoins on a ce soir encore des
joueurs blessés
d'année en année comme clément chantôme
qui aurait pu effectivement asseoir le
jeu et nous dire on est là en nationale
2 aujourd'hui versailles ou pas
versailles
même si du respect c'est un derby je
pense que les joueurs sont motivés mais
pas plus qu'un autre match je pense que
c'est la victoire impérative si c'est un
match où on ira on ira jouer à lorient
dimanche avec un seul point
là ça sera compliqué merci olivier ses
musiques le match commencera à 20h ici à
poissy merci michael et vous nous
commenter ou reviendrai sur ce match
dans notre édition de demain jeudi
pour refermer ce journal le retour de
votre rubrique hebdomadaire dans les
salles à chaque mercredi nous nous
rendons dans les cinémas asie blinois
pour faire un focus sur leur
programmation ce soir le responsable du
grenier à sel à trappes vous présente un
évènement à venir dans sa salle et c'est
au micro de patrick jacques de dixmude à
[Musique]
antoine de maximy sera au cinéma le
grenier à sel vendredi 4 septembre à
20h45
il viendra présenter son film j'irai
mourir dans les carpates on connaît tous
antoine de maximy puisque ça fait 15 ans
qu'ils présentent
j'irai dormir chez vous et il a décidé
d'en faire une fiction où quelque chose
se passerait mal et donc on suit
l'enquète il y à sa monteuse qui était
en cas restés en france qui récupère ses
vidéos et elle fait une enquête pour
retrouver antoine de maximy qui a
disparu dans les carpates
alors on connait tous entendu maxime où
on connait tous ces chemises rouges
il viendra au grenier à sel pour nous
montrer sa chemise rouge ces caméras et
nous rencontrer donc vous pouvez
réserver vos places sur notre site
internet cinéma grenier à sel points
comme et je vous dis à vendredi
est-ce que je peux dormir chez vous des
bruits c'est quand même très bizarre de
faire ce genre de geste discrètement là
on dirait qu'ils complotent
voyez imputé la mort vous croyez qu'on
pourrait retrouver
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi belle soirée à tous sur tv
[Musique]